Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Imaginez une forêt sombre,
comme celle-là, à la tombée de la nuit.
Vous êtes obligé de la traverser
pour rentrer chez vous,
Et comme d’habitude,
quand on en a vraiment besoin,
la batterie de votre portable est à plat.
Vous n’avez pas non plus de lampe de poche
car maintenant, elle est sur le portable.
Pas le choix,
il faut traverser cette forêt.
Vous vous engagez
courageusement sur le chemin.
Vous entendez le crissement
de vos pas sur les feuilles mortes.
Vous entendez un peu plus loin
le bruissement du vent, les feuilles.
Vous entendez des craquements
de branches au loin.
Il vous semble voir des ombres
à droite, à gauche,
et vous entendez des cris d’animaux
que vous ne connaissiez même pas.
Là, si vous êtes comme tout être humain
normalement constitué,
le rythme de votre cœur va augmenter,
va battre plus fort.
Vous allez accélérer le pas.
Vous allez peut-être même courir
pour sortir au plus vite de cette forêt.
Et cette situation ici,
que vous avez vécue par la pensée -
Merci d’avoir participé
à cette expérience de pensée.
Vous n’aviez pas le choix
puisque je vous l’ai un peu imposée.
On peut expliquer notre comportement
dans cette situation
par les biais cognitifs.
Que sont ces biais cognitifs,
ce nom un peu curieux ?
C’est un phénomène assez passionnant
et encore assez peu connu
qui se passerait à l’intérieur
de notre cerveau
et qui nous influencerait à notre insu.
Un peu comme Monsieur Jourdain,
le bourgeois gentilhomme de Molière,
qui faisait de la prose sans le savoir.
Dans « biais cognitif », il y a
deux mots, « biais » et « cognitif ».
La psychologie, ce n’est pas compliqué.
L’idée de biais,
c’est l’idée d’erreur, on le sait,
et cognitif, c’est tout ce qui relève
de la connaissance,
du savoir, de l’information.
Donc un biais cognitif,
c’est une erreur de raisonnement
due à l’utilisation d’une heuristique.
Mais un mot compliqué pour un autre,
on ne comprend pas plus ce que c’est.
Il nous faut définir maintenant
ce qu’est une heuristique,
un raisonnement court, facile,
rapide et automatique.
Donc le biais cognitif, finalement,
c’est une erreur de raisonnement
due à l’utilisation
d’un raisonnement court,
facile, rapide et automatique.
Comme dans notre situation.
L’heuristique, c’est d’identifier
les bruits qu’on entend,
les ombres qu’on voit, à des dangers,
à des choses qui sont
potentiellement dangereuses
et d’avoir peur et de fuir.
Ces heuristiques, on le voit bien,
ne sont pas très utiles
du point de vue de la connaissance,
parce qu’on va se tromper le plus souvent.
Ces bruits qu’on a entendus,
c’était le vent,
c’était sans doute des animaux inoffensifs
ou des êtres humains
qui ne nous veulent pas de mal -
après tout, la plupart
ne nous veut pas de mal,
heureusement.
Et par contre,
cette heuristique qui n’est pas utile
pour la connaissance,
est très utile pour la survie.
Parce que si, dans les quelques rares cas
où il s’agissait réellement d’un ours
ou d’un loup, qui sont d’ailleurs
de retour bientôt dans nos forêts,
il était utile de fuir et de courir,
et d’avoir peur.
Et voilà comment on explique l'apparition
de ces heuristiques dans nos cerveaux.
Il ne faut pas oublier que nous sommes
les descendants des descendants
de celles et ceux qui ont survécu,
ceux qui n’ont pas eu
cette peur dans les forêts
en fait, n’ont pas eu de descendance.
Et donc nous, finalement, on est issus
de celles et ceux qui ont eu le plus peur.
Donc, c’est l’origine
de ces biais cognitifs.
On fait l’hypothèse, vous l’avez
entendu dans une précédente conférence,
que l’on aurait en fait dans nos têtes
non pas un, mais deux systèmes de pensée
à l’intérieur d’un même cerveau.
Ces deux systèmes de pensée -
à nouveau, la psychologie,
ce n’est pas compliqué,
on les a appelés le système un
et le système deux.
On ne peut faire plus simple.
Vous avez ce livre de Daniel Kahneman,
prix Nobel d’économie et psychologue,
qui a popularisé cette idée.
Le système un, le lièvre,
et le système deux, la tortue.
Le système un, ce serait justement
ce mode de pensée intuitif, rapide,
heuristique, qu'on peut nommer
un peu l'intuition.
On n’a pas le temps de réfléchir vraiment
et on ressent les choses.
Mais nous aurions
un deuxième système de pensée
qu’on appelle le système deux,
analytique, plus lent, plus coûteux.
Le système déductif.
Là, vous pouvez imaginer,
quand on fait des maths,
on a chaud, ça fait mal à la tête,
on a faim, on a besoin de sucre,
on est fatigué.
Donc c’est vraiment ce système-là.
En fait, ces deux systèmes
coexisteraient dans nos têtes.
C’est-à-dire que, par défaut,
c’est le système un qui s’applique
quand on est fatigué le soir
et sur nos téléphones,
qu’on partage des informations,
en ne lisant pas complètement
l’article qu’on a partagé,
on est en mode système un.
Par contre, le système deux,
ce serait justement
quand on réfléchit un peu et on peut -
Ce système un, tout le monde l’aurait,
c’est le fonctionnement par défaut.
Ça explique pourquoi les plus grands
génies se sont aussi trompés.
Einstein ne croyait pas
à la physique quantique,
Newton était alchimiste,
les grands astronomes, Kepler, Galilée
étaient aussi astrologues, etc.
Donc tout le monde aurait, même
les plus grands, les plus intelligents,
ce système qui peut les biaiser.
L’intelligence, finalement, ce serait
l’exercice de ce système deux
qui prend beaucoup d’efforts.
Voilà comment on explique ça.
Remarquez que cette définition
de l’intelligence renvoie
à un grand philosophe
qui s’appelle Serge Gainsbourg
et qui a dit un jour que la connerie,
c'est la décontraction de l'intelligence.
Il était quelque part
un peu précurseur de cette théorie.
Les recherches en psychologie ont montré
que le système un est lié à l’utilisation
de toutes sortes de raccourcis de pensée,
des stéréotypes, des croyances
non vérifiées, on va dire.
Le système deux serait plutôt lié
à un mode de pensée plus critique,
plus abstrait, plus difficile.
Dans ces biais, il y en a des centaines
qui ont été identifiés,
mais il y en a beaucoup
qui se ressemblent,
on peut parler de quelques dizaines,
on va dire.
Un que j’aime bien, c’est celui-là,
le biais de corrélation illusoire,
parce qu’en fait il explique
beaucoup de croyances très différentes.
Le biais de corrélations illusoires,
c’est l’idée que quand on perçoit
une coïncidence,
deux événements qui arrivent ensemble,
on a l’impression qu’ils sont liés
et on aura l’impression
qu’ils sont liés par un lien de causalité.
Exemple : qui, dans cette salle,
a l’impression qu’il arrive mal à dormir
les soirs de pleine lune ?
Vous vous méfiez, vous pensez,
biais cognitifs,
on parle d’erreur, on n’ose pas,
mais vous aurez quand même un peu raison.
Ici, c’est une croyance très
répandue, très ancienne
et qui réapparaît toujours, car
justement, elle peut être provoquée
par un de ces biais cognitifs.
C’est-à-dire que, dans cette situation,
un soir, une nuit,
vous vous réveillez,
vous n’arrivez plus à dormir.
Vous levez pour aller boire
un verre d’eau,
Vous voyez une magnifique lumière blanche
inonder votre appartement.
Vous regardez dehors, c’est magnifique,
l’obscure clarté de la lune dehors.
Et vous voyez ce paysage merveilleux.
Et vous allez remarquer ceci.
Si ça arrive une fois, vous direz
que c’est une coïncidence,
deux fois, trois fois,
cinq fois, dix fois.
Là, vous allez vous dire que non,
il y a plus de coïncidence,
Dix fois, la pleine lune
m’empêche de dormir.
Mais ça pourrait être vrai.
C’est peut-être vrai,
mais en fait, il y a aussi beaucoup
de chances que ce soit faux.
Et le problème,
c’est que vous oubliez un peu
les nuits d’insomnie
où en fait la nuit était noire,
parce qu’on s’est levé, on n’a rien vu.
L’absence de quelque chose
ne se remarque pas,
seulement la présence de quelque chose.
On ne va pas aller à la fenêtre et dire :
« Quelle merveilleuse
absence de pleine lune ! »
On est bien d'accord.
On est focalisé.
La coïncidence nous impressionne,
mais l’absence de coïncidence, pas.
Et on oublie aussi, quand on a bien dormi,
si la lune était pleine ou non,
puisqu’on a bien dormi, on n’a pas vu.
Il faudrait prendre
les quatre cases de ce tableau
pour vraiment faire un raisonnement
un peu plus développé
prendre un grand nombre
de nuits, des milliers de personnes…
Et, en général, quand on fait ça,
on constate qu’il n’y a pas de lien
vraiment entre pleine lune et sommeil.
Mais il y a des études scientifiques
qui sont faites.
A Fribourg, on a un laboratoire du sommeil
où on étudie différentes choses,
et ils ont remarqué que peut-être,
la lumière pourrait avoir
un effet sur le sommeil.
Ce n’est peut-être pas la pleine lune
en tant que telle,
mais sa lumière qui pourrait
non pas créer des insomnies,
mais en tout cas diminuer un peu
la qualité du sommeil.
Ce biais de corrélation illusoire
est très présent dans tous les domaines.
Dans le domaine médical, par exemple,
quand on tombe malade,
on va chercher à guérir
et à faire quelque chose.
On va prendre des infusions de plantes,
de l’homéopathie,
on va essayer peut-être
une prière chamanique, différentes choses.
Et on va guérir parce que,
heureusement, la plupart du temps,
on guérit.
C’est une chance, et effectivement
l’heuristique, ça va être de penser
que ce qu’on a fait nous a guéri.
De nouveau,
c’est possible que ce soit vrai,
mais il y a aussi de fortes chances
que ça ne soit pas vrai.
Et là est tout le problème.
On va vite croire
que ce qu’on a fait nous a guéri,
mais en fait, ça s’est fait
en très peu de temps,
une fois guéri, on se dit :
« c’est ce que j’ai pris qui m’a guéri. »
Et pour le savoir, il faut des siècles
de mathématiques, de statistiques.
Il faut des dizaines d’années
pour se former à la recherche médicale,
faire un doctorat,
puis faire une recherche
avec des centaines de personnes
dans un groupe contrôle,
dans un groupe expérimental, tester,
publier les résultats
dans une revue scientifique et ensuite,
attendre que les scientifiques
du monde entier répliquent votre étude
et fassent des méta-analyses,
des synthèses d’études.
Vous voyez le travail
qu’il faut pour savoir.
L’heuristique prend quelques minutes
ou quelques secondes même pour ce faire.
Cette heuristique, elle est présente
dans tous les comportements superstitieux.
« Un vendredi 13, j’ai eu de la chance,
donc du coup, j’y crois. »
car on est frappé par la coïncidence.
La télépathie : on pense à quelqu’un
qui n’a pas appelé depuis longtemps,
Une heure, un jour après, il nous appelle.
On est frappé, on se dit :
« C’est la transmission de pensée ! »
Mais on oublie
le nombre de fois où on a pensé
à lui et qu’il n’a pas appelé.
Ou évidemment le nombre de fois
où cette personne a appelé
et on n’a pas pensé à elle avant,
mais ça nous frappe moins, on a oublié.
Vous voyez comment ça marche ?
Et aussi les sportives et sportifs.
Si par hasard, un jour, ils ont la vieille
chaussette d’un arrière-grand-parent
et qu’ils ont gagné le match avec,
ils vont la porter toute leur vie.
Et peut-être ne pas la laver,
ça arrive aussi parfois
pour le grand plaisir
des collègues de vestiaire.
Le plus drôle : ces croyances peuvent
devenir vraies à force d’y croire.
C’est-à-dire que cette chaussette,
si le sportif ou la sportive l’oublie,
il ou elle va moins bien jouer parce
qu’il sera stressé et va moins performer.
Donc cette chaussette devient
réellement efficace par la pensée.
Dans le complotisme,
on a aussi  ce même biais.
Pendant la pandémie, certains disaient :
« C’est bizarre, le virus vient de Chine,
la 5G aussi.
Donc il y a un lien entre les deux. »
La 5G activerait quelque chose,
et c’est sérieux,
on dirait une plaisanterie, mais des gens
se sont attaqués à des antennes 5G.
donc ce n’était pas une plaisanterie.
On a d’autres biais, qu’on range
dans la catégorie des biais cognitifs,
plus psychologiques.
Ce n’est pas forcément
inscrit dans nos cerveaux.
Ces biais inscrits dans nos cerveaux
sont plus liés à la survie.
Les biais psychologiques,
c’est plutôt pour se sentir bien.
On les apprend dans notre enfance
ou dans notre éducation.
Par exemple, un biais psychologique,
le biais de supériorité illusoire,
c’est que nous avons toutes et tous
l’impression d’être mieux que la moyenne.
Donc en moyenne, les gens pensent
être mieux que la moyenne.
Ce n’est pas possible,
sinon, la moyenne augmenterait.
Statistiquement, c’est impossible.
Si la distribution est symétrique,
on a une moitié des gens
au-dessus de la moyenne
et l’autre en dessous.
C’est très utile psychologiquement,
imaginez l’inverse,
penser être moins bien que la moyenne
mène tout droit à la dépression.
Quelque part, c’est une erreur,
mais c’est une douce illusion
qui nous fait du bien.
Mais ce biais psychologique,
ce biais de supériorité illusoire,
peut devenir dangereux.
On a entendu pendant la pandémie des gens
devenir spécialistes en virologie
après avoir visionné
quelques vidéos YouTube.
On a des spécialistes en géopolitique
dès le début de la guerre en Ukraine.
On a parlé de réchauffement
climatique l’été passé
et on a eu des spécialistes
en climatologie sur Internet.
Gilles Belvaux, le dessinateur,
a illustré ce biais de cette façon-là.
Vous avez aussi des biais sociaux.
Le plus simple
étant le biais de conformisme
qu’on connaît bien
chez nos adolescentes et adolescents.
Mais les adultes, on est tout aussi
influencés par ce genre de choses.
Ces biais cognitifs expliquent
beaucoup de choses
et notamment des croyances
qu’on voit actuellement.
Certains pensent qu’il y avait
de l’électricité sur les pyramides.
(Rires)
D’autres pensent que la véritable forme
de la Terre, c’est celle-ci.
Ce serait la seule photo
non photoshopée par la NASA.
D’autres personnes encore disséminent
des fake news, des fausses croyances.
En fait, nous sommes assez réceptifs
à toutes ces croyances
du fait de ces biais cognitifs
qui nous font accepter
des choses un peu trop facilement.
Je ne serais pas là ce soir
si seuls les biais cognitifs existaient.
On les étudie depuis les années 70
en psychologie, donc c’est assez vieux.
Mais pourquoi je suis ici ce soir ?
C’est sans doute à cause
ou grâce à Internet en fait.
Pourquoi toutes ces croyances et
pourquoi on en parle autant actuellement ?
Il y a dix ans, j'en parlais
beaucoup moins.
On en parle beaucoup ces temps
parce qu’Internet
nous donne de l’information,
nous donne des fausses informations,
des choses non vérifiées
que nos biais cognitifs adorent en fait.
C’est un peu comme le sucre
qu’on devait consommer
pour des raisons de survie
et que maintenant on peut surconsommer,
on a aussi ce problème-là
avec nos biais cognitifs -
en tout cas, c’est l’hypothèse.
On arrive en conclusion
à un paradoxe de notre monde moderne,
qui est de plus en plus scientifique.
On dépense de plus en plus d’argent
dans la recherche scientifique,
on a des millions de scientifiques,
ça augmente toujours.
Il y a des milliers d’articles
qui sortent chaque jour
et il y a aussi une augmentation
du quotient intellectuel de la population
pendant le 20e siècle.
L’intelligence augmentait linéairement,
l’éducation aussi,
donc on devient de plus en plus
intelligent quelque part.
Mais en même temps, on a aussi toujours
des croyances abracadabrantes
qui coexistent avec cette intelligence.
Ces biais cognitifs nous permettent
d’expliquer comment.
Voilà ici ce paradoxe illustré
en quelques dessins.
Vous avez donc le travail
de nombreux scientifiques.
Un des plus grands défis technologiques
pour donner accès à Internet.
Et tout ça pour que Billy
pense que la Terre est plate.
Voilà, je vous remercie
de votre attention.
(Applaudissements)